[Musik]
flugausfälle und verspätungen der
arbeitskampf zwischen lufthansa und
flugbegleiter gewerkschaft weitet sich
aus exit auf wiedervorlage london und
brüssel brüten über einem neuen fahrplan
seine sprache sind bilder als erster
fotograf erhält sebastiao salgado den
friedenspreis des deutschen buchhandels
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem sonntag norbert könig ist auch
wieder dabei für den sport wer heute mit
einer der vier lufthansa töchter fliegen
wollte german oder euro ins sun express
oder cityline wurde am morgen von der
meldung der flugbegleitergewerkschaft
ufo überrascht statt sechs heute 19
stunden streik bis mitternacht hinter
dem arbeitskampf steckt auch ein tiefes
zerwürfnis zwischen der gewerkschaft und
dem lufthansa konzern
isabel de la vega der flughafen hamburg
ein gutes dutzend flüge der lufthansa
tochter eurowings ist hier gestrichen
worden das große chaos aber ist
ausgeblieben
die meisten passagiere wurden informiert
und umgebucht wir hoffen dass wir
entweder ein ersatzflug bekommen oder
mit dem zug fahren können eins von
beiden aber wir müssen heute noch nach
köln es geht der gewerkschaft um mehr
lohn teilzeitregelungen und eine bessere
altersabsicherung vor allem aber um die
eigene existenz denn die ufo kämpft mit
internen querelen ist geschwächt
ich glaube dass die ufos
spartengewerkschaft für die lufthansa in
der vergangenheit im großes problem
dargestellt hat eine politik der tausend
nadelstiche hart fahren können und die
lufthansa wittert meines abends jetzt
die chance die gewerkschaft aus
rechtlichen und taktischen gründen stark
ins abseits zu drängen
erst sollte die lufthansa bestreikt
werden die kündigte dann aber
kurzfristig eine lohnsteigerung von 2
prozent für das kabinenpersonal an
worauf die ufo den streik auf die
lufthansa töchter verlagert
der vorwurf nun die lufthansa
verunsichert die mitarbeiter teilweise
werden sie bedroht jetzt an diesem
wochenende erst geht es nicht mehr nur
um arbeitsrechtliche konsequenzen
sondern auch um arbeitsplatzverluste in
den raum gestellt wird zu den konzern
wiederum ist die ufo kein legitimer
verhandlungspartner die streiks der ufo
sind rechtswidrig und zwar deshalb weil
sowohl der gewerkschafts status der ufo
als auch die vertretungsberechtigten des
ufo vorstandes einfach nicht geklärt
sind
am ende müssen dass die gerichte
entscheiden
nach syrien nach der türkische einmarsch
in den kurdengebieten hat international
massiv kritik ausgelöst
im zdf sagte aussenminister maß das
türkische vorgehen stehen nicht im
einklang mit dem völkerrecht
im moment haben wir gott sei dank eine
waffenruhe die auch einigermaßen hält
und wir werden alles daran setzen dass
diese waffenruhe nicht nur fünf tage
hält sondern dass sie länger andauert
und damit diese innovation zunächst
einmal gestoppt wird und dann muss man
mit der türkei auch reden und dafür
brauchen wir den dialog wie es dort
weitergehen kann
das ganze interview mit dem
außenminister sehen sie gleich im
anschluss in berlin direkt zum break
sind der britische premier johnson ist
nach wie vor überzeugt davon dass
großbritannien zum 31 oktober die eu
verlässt aber er hat nach seiner
niederlage im parlament gestern
gezwungenermaßen bei der eu eine
fristverlängerung bis ende januar
beantragt die eu allerdings reagiert
darauf verhalten stefan leifert in
brüssel warum
ja das ist zum einen der versuch der eu
seite angesichts der irrungen und
wirrungen in london jetzt ein bisschen
demonstrative gelassenheit zu zeigen
andererseits besteht aber auch noch gar
kein handlungsbedarf so lange in london
noch die aussicht besteht den deal von
boris johnson irgendwie durchs parlament
zu bekommen sollte ihm das diese woche
gelingen dann wird der antrag auf
verlängerung sowieso überflüssig wenn
der de von beust johnson im parlament
diese woche scheitert dann wird sich die
eu seite mit der frage einer
verlängerung auseinandersetzen und
könnte dann relativ schnell darüber
entscheiden und diese entscheidung würde
wohl positiv ausfallen es wird dann eine
verlängerung geben so viel kann man
jetzt schon sagen zwar ist die ermattung
angesichts des wechsels ziemlich groß
aber die devise auf eu seite ist nach
wie vor einen ungeregelten braxton auf
jeden fall zu vermeiden
deswegen tut die eu jetzt erst einmal
nichts und guckt gespannt nach london
dankeschön für diese einschätzung aus
brüssel stefan leifert bei der
parlamentswahl in der schweiz liegt die
rechtspopulistische svp nach ersten
hochrechnungen vorn trotz großer
verluste bleibt sie stärkste kraft
zugleich wird den schweizern aber
offenbar auch umwelt- und klimaschutz
wichtiger die beiden grünen parteien
erreichen zusammen mehr
20 prozent das sind gut acht
prozentpunkte mehr als 2005 10
trotz demonstrationsverbot sind in
hongkong erneut zehntausende gegen die
regierung auf die straße gegangen
der zunächst friedliche protest
eskalierte als gewaltbereite
demonstranten geschäfte verwüsteten und
brandsätze auf eine polizeiwache warfen
die beamten setzten tränengas und
wasserwerfer ein
premiere beim friedenspreis des
deutschen buchhandels zum ersten mal
bekommt ihn ein fotograf der brasilianer
sebastian salgado jahre verbrachte er
bei indigenen stämmen oder in
krisengebieten seine mission sei es
licht auf ungerechtigkeit zu werfen sagt
er
in schwarz weiß peter theißen über einen
helden des friedens wie es heute in der
laudatio hieß
als sebastian salgado den friedenspreis
des deutschen buchhandels erhält da wird
ein fotograf geehrt der wie kein zweiter
die geschichte der menschheit der
letzten jahrzehnte dokumentiert hat die
welt der arbeiter in den bergwerken etwa
kriege und die vertreibung von millionen
von menschen
die mehrheit der menschheit lebt unter
schwierigsten umständen in totaler
instabilität in totaler unsicherheit
diese soziale wirklichkeit zu
fotografieren und der welt zu zeigen das
halte ich für extrem wichtig als er die
völkermord in ruanda und auf dem balkan
miterlebt da verzweifelt zagato fast an
der menschheit und liegt todkrank seine
kamera zur seite eine idee seiner frau
julia bringt ihn ins leben zurück auf
den ausgedörrten fan land seiner eltern
in brasilien beginnen sie ein
gigantisches wiederaufforstungsprojekt
zweieinhalb millionen bäume bis heute
die erde hat mich geheilt
ich wurde geheilt wodurch den bau dieses
waldes durch die rückkehr der vögel und
ihre und in senken
wim wenders hat diesem außergewöhnlichen
fotografen und menschen im film das salz
der erde ein denkmal gesetzt
nur einer der so mit anderen gelitten
hat sie begleitet hat mitgegangen ist
ihnen zeit geschenkt hat nur so einer
kann uns auch die augen aufmachen und
sagen schaut was ist noch alles gibt was
es noch alles gibt die schönheit aber
auch die verletzlichkeit des planeten
das zeigt saal gardot in seinem jüngsten
großen wagnisses um uns staunen zu
lassen und zu helfen zu bewahren
den schlimmsten moment seines lebens
hätte er in ruanda erlebt hatte heute
gesagt und der schönste moment war als
er seine frau geheiratet hat 50 jahre
sind die beiden verheiratet
jetzt kommst du mit so was sehen jetzt
können wir auch bestätigt jeweiligen
partnern und mit einer entschieden dass
niederlage im tennis im vorjahr hatte
julia görges das turnier in luxemburg
gewonnen in ihrem siebzehnter finale der
karriere war dann aber doch die lettin
elina ostapenko stärker nichts war es
mit der titelverteidigung julia görges
konnte nur im ersten satz gegen jena
ostapenko spielerische akzente setzen
verlor trotzdem mit 4 zu 6
im zweiten durchgang war sie chancenlos
gegen die ehemalige french open-siegerin
ostapenko nummer 63 der weltrangliste
diktierte das geschehen nach belieben
schaffte zwei breaks nacheinander und
hatte beim stand von 5 2 1 matchball
ein doppelfehler beendete die begegnung
klare niederlage aber aufsteigende form
bei julia görges
bayern münchen muss mehrere monate auf
niklas süle verzichten die knie
verletzung des nationalspielers bei der
partie gestern in augsburg hat sich als
kreuzbandriss herausgestellt
im ersten sonntagsspiel verliert
aufsteiger paderborn bei aufsteiger köln
mit 0 zu 3 und bleibt abgeschlagen
tabellenletzter
köln verlässt die abstiegsränge und noch
mal bronze für deutschland zum abschluss
der bahnrad em theo reinhardt und
maximilian beyer werden in appeldorn
dritte im zweier mannschaftsfahren dem
sogenannten madison nach einem frühen
runden gewinnen liegen theo reinhardt
und maximilian beyer beim ersten rennen
lange zeit in führung gegen ende wird
dann aber das dänische duo normann
hansen und michael mörköv immer stärker
sie sichern sich eine sprintwertung nach
der nächsten und gewinnen mit 52 punkten
souverän den europameistertitel in der
letzten von 200 runden ziehen die
niederländer noch an deutschland vorbei
silber für jan willem van chip und juli
harwig theo reinhardt und maximilian
beyer auf dem dritten platz die
insgesamt neunte deutsche medaille bei
diesen bahnrad europameisterschaften so
viel von sonntag sport danke norbert
noch das wetter im osten und südosten
meist freundlich sonst mehr wolken vor
allem im nordwesten und südwesten regen
13 bis 23 grad
so fiel in aller kürze von uns um
viertel vor zehn heute journal mit
christian sievers morgen begrüßt sich
petra gerster wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen entspannten sonntag ab